i think i'll play a game i was intending
just to play chess this stream
um i'll join the pool and try and play
high level chess
i'll take breaks between games to answer
questions
and ryan the hunter i've got leftover
bits from
france's battle streams so here you get
some one dollar
thanks for the leftover bits i
appreciate that
i'll go towards the t fund also welcome
back john how's it going
oh we have a london we're following the
carlson ding game
ding played queen b6
didn't play the interesting move um g6
and i didn't look at the game too
closely but it seemed to be like a
relevant london theater i'd love the
content nice to be able to see your
youtube videos
oh welcome back akd 707 thanks for the
bits
okay this is a line i've found to be
very pleasant for white
i'm just kind of chilling okay after
this game i'll show
there is a cool idea for black in this
line
which we're not going to go into
i'll play c3
but yeah for now i mean i have two
bishops
black has some damage pawn structure
probably knight b3 eventually knight d4
with some kind of queen f3
the queen can actually be quite good on
h3
and target the pawn very likely we'll
see g6
also just want to play like rook d1
maybe rook fd1 love your content eric
don't mess with the walrus
oh yeah don't mess with the walrus
you've learned
i want to play i know a5a4 is coming
i'm actually not sure what to do here
queen h3 maybe queen h3 first
yeah so i'm getting out of this knight
d2 fork like the ventral knight d2 fork
and then
i want to play rook b1
start with rook b1
and timing doesn't quite work out okay
let's take a knight d4
it's a move i didn't want to play but i
couldn't play a4 because my knight was
hanging
i couldn't move my knight because knight
d2
let's throw the rook d1
oh this square is annoying okay so let's
take
so it's knight versus bishop
queen g3 bishop d6
play rook d2 first there's only one open
file also thanks
and kale for subbing okay so i'll double
off in the file
black's probably doubling up two
sneaky queen move
might be relevant at some point
maybe c4 at the right moment or g4
or 96 96 is no good
play queen e7 i'm just trying to poke
around i feel like i just robbed a house
with this move
like i'm it's a very unwelcome visitor
i haven't robbed the house yet i just
broken i've broken into the house
but i'm about to rob the house somehow
unless bishop f6 happens
ooh bishop f6 is a queen trap
wait that's not pleasant
i have um knight f3 weird move
now f3 is a really weird move let's do
it
oh b2 hangs
okay that was really bad
i'm just losing all my pawns
my house is being robbed
uh where's my counter play
g4
so i just want to
want to complicate things as much as
possible
there's a cool mating idea queen e6
uh here here here here here and then
queen h4 made in the end
so king h6 queen each was mate
wow i called it i called it that was so
nice
i saw that so i saw that in this
position
i was a little bit too slow to draw the
arrows
i feel like we both got robbed
wonka bar 23 redeemed hello oh hello to
wonka bar
welcome and hello to the future youtube
people
if this goes on youtube
chess is like robbing a house that was
fun that was
that was actually not a great game um
given that queen e7 was
yeah it was a little bit too over
adventurous
knight f3 was actually just a really bad
move
oh everyone's saying wow i'm glad you're
impressed
i probably should have played queen h4
back and just admit
that i can't rob a house oh there's 96
what does 96 wait how does this even
work
96 takes oh
oh this is such a sweet move
because if takes there's there's mating
ideas so knight's actually useful on e6
more useful on e6 than it is on f3
oh that's such a nice move
so rook d6 was a mistake
yeah in general i enjoy this line for
lights
um oh f3
f3 could have been useful kick away the
knight this pawn isn't so weak
they kill us thanks for subbing i was
going to show something
like in the opening i think there's some
idea for black
where is it like castling
and then
there's some d4 idea like if if um yeah
if c3 here then d4
is like a really surprised move no one
knows this
most people who enter this line um
don't really know theory because it's
not so pretty for black
but d4 is very strong
vision bits oh thanks kingston
so the idea here is if white takes with
either pawn the knight will take the
queen will take and the bishops are
forked
so let's imagine takes
oh actually maybe bishop takes d4 is
stronger for some reason
stockfish knows best and takes takes
so it's a cool cool way to
like get um
maybe get white out of other prep or to
out prep white
on this computer graph man
it was a funny funny roller coaster
so yeah if i put this on youtube thanks
people for watching be sure to follow on
twitch
so you can witness stuff like this in
real time